now leftists as we know are determined
to induct children into the lgbt cult as
early as possible and by any means at
their disposal
that's why we must be totally determined
and dedicated
to protecting children from this abuse
and that's also all the more reason why
it was so dispiriting and uh really
frankly tragic on friday a day before
the sodom and gomorrah festivities
kicked off to see fox news
jump on the lgbt grooming bandwagon
actually fox didn't just join the
bandwagon they skipped all the way to
the front of it they ran out in front of
the bandwagon so they could be you know
leading it
during their america's newsroom
broadcast fox ran a package by reporter
brian yanus
uh promoting and celebrating the
transing of children they were not this
was not a report reporting on this
controversy
but uh no celebrating promoting it
actively
the propaganda was so radical so far to
the left
that i would have honestly been
surprised to see it on cnn
or even msnbc
but even those outlets have not quite
gone as far to the left on the trans
issue as fox apparently has at least
with this report
that's how bad it is
it's certainly bad enough that i have to
call them out i appear on fox news often
i've benefited from the platform from
the visibility that they've given me
it's quite possible that by attacking
them publicly i've now ruined that
relationship so be it in that case
they really left us no choice
the segment was that bad
but don't take my word for it let's go
let's go through this and kind of watch
it together
just so we can see how bad this really
is here it is
walking down the street
you wouldn't
think anything different
fourteen-year-old ryland whittington is
a typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister brinley are
a typical family the only difference
though in ryland's eyes is what this
family can mean to the tens of thousands
of kids under 18 who identify as
transgender we put our story out there
so people could
see that like there's another family out
there that
is
going through what we're going through
or there's another family who's proud of
who they are before rylan could even
speak he managed to tell his parents
that he is a boy i could just see it it
wasn't him trying to be
a brat it was like painful it was truly
painful for him to have to wear feminine
clothing and and for us constantly
telling him that you're a girl and
unlike some trans kids when rylan came
out at age five a few years later he had
the full support of his parents
before the girl could speak
she was communicating that she's a boy
before she could speak
fox wants us to believe that babies can
choose their own gender
children so young that they they don't
yet have the ability to communicate in
words
can still according to fox consent to
begin a gender transition and on what
basis
where is the evidence for this
wild assertion
how do we know that babies have a
concept of quote unquote gender identity
well because because here's why because
this baby didn't want to wear dresses
that's it that's the whole story and
that's the whole sword they want to
overchat by this logic of course
almost every baby girl is really a boy
there are no girls left in the world it
turns out because almost every young
girl in the world and that has ever
existed in the world has gone through at
least a phase
where they didn't want to wear the
clothes their parents put them in
every boy has also gone through this
phase
so maybe every boy is really a girl and
every girl is really a boy we'll just
we'll just trade places make it simple
there are no girls left in the world
except boys the only girls left in the
world are boys and the only uh boys left
are girls
this is the utter irredeemable madness
that flows from the kind of demented
half-baked incomprehensible pseudo-logic
you just heard from fox
never mind the fact that once again
the trans activists
are rigidly enforcing gender roles while
com claiming that they want to break
down generals they are rigidly enforcing
them the idea that that the girl you
know just might be a girl who doesn't
like quote unquote girly things that
never even occurs to these parents or to
any trans activist
well she's two years old she doesn't
want to wear a dress maybe she just
doesn't like the dresses
not to mention the fact that the one
dress that we saw there was like
hideously ugly so we could hardly blame
her for not wanting to wear that one
i mean that could be it if your
two-year-old daughter doesn't want to
wear the dress it could just be like she
just is two doesn't want to wear a dress
right now
or or she could really be a boy
oh yeah that must be it she's a boy
so according to the trans activists and
to the left and now to fox news
girls
must like girly things and if they don't
then they're boys
so good news ladies you can be anything
you want to be you have
self-determination
nobody can tell you what to do you are
your own person be yourself
unless you don't like the color pink or
if you prefer not to wear dresses and
then you can't even be a girl anymore
you're now a boy
here's some injections to sterilize you
and permanently alter your voice oh
we'll also have to remove your breasts
you're not gonna be needing those ever
in your whole life we've decided because
you don't like wearing dresses
you don't like wearing dresses so we're
gonna chop your breasts off and you'll
just you'll never have that bodily
function ever again
this is the deranged dangerous insanity
that fox news is selling
and it gets worse listen
initially there was some pushback from
us and trying to understand this we were
confused like most people are we thought
that gender and sexuality were the same
thing it took us a while to figure out
that those two things are different and
that children actually do recognize
their gender identity very young some of
them not all but they listened to rylan
and to hillary's conservative faith for
me it's just a deep spiritual belief
that you believe in god and he you know
created us the way he wanted us well
then yes he created ryland just the way
he is and they listened to families they
met in support groups there was a father
who was sitting across the table he says
you have no idea how lucky you are to be
here which kind of took me back i didn't
at that point consider myself lucky to
be there and he said you know our our
child had displayed
this gender dysphoria or this gender
misalignment at at the same age that
rylan has
and
we didn't listen and we pushed back that
pushback led that child to turn to
self-harm as a teenager which 60 percent
of trans and non-binary kids engage in
according to the trevor project more
than 50 percent consider suicide that
for me was the turning point i didn't
want to see rylan to go through that i'd
rather have a living son than a dead
daughter
like i told you this is actually worse
more radical more extreme than anything
we've heard on msnbc at this point
up to this point on this subject
they're packing all of the most extreme
and nonsensical trans agenda talking
points into one piece of propaganda
we've already heard that a girl chose
her own gender when she was a toddler
and then came out when she was five
that's an actual sentence that was
uttered on the air
on fox news
when she came out when she was five
she's been on the earth for only five
years she has almost no understanding of
the world or herself or human biology
she not gonna be a legal adult for
another 13 years her brain won't be
fully developed for another 20 years
and yet she was able to make this
decision for herself
and then we're told that the parents
conservative faith is what drove them
mommy munchausen says that god doesn't
make mistakes and she's right about that
yet her conviction that god doesn't make
mistakes is what led her to the
conclusion that her daughter was born in
the wrong body
and was really supposed to be her son
and the only way to fix it is with drugs
and surgery
on the contrary it turns out that
according to her god does make mistakes
he makes pretty big ones it turns out
there are some major screw-ups on the
heavenly assembly line and somehow boy
souls are put into girl bodies and vice
versa
and this seems to be happening a lot
more recently too somehow
must be a new management up at the
factory
probably should review their training
protocols i don't know
no by mommy uh munchausen's telling
god is a bumbling fool
an idiot
whose work needs to be checked and
corrected with the help of the
pharmaceutical industry that's what she
thinks
next we're given a few alleged facts and
figures from the far left propagandist
organization the trevor project which
claims that alleged trans kids will kill
themselves if they're not allowed to
transition their gender
i'd rather have a living son than a dead
daughter mommy munchausen tells us
this is the macabre bumper sticker
slogan that has served to justify the
butchery of thousands of children's
children there's no data to back it up
nothing
in fact as we discussed last week the
data shows that gender transition
does not decrease the suicide rate
in fact the data shows that it increases
it
suicidality is highest a decade after
transition that's what the data shows
the suicide claim from trans activists
is nothing but emotional blackmail
in the case of these horrendous evil
parents it's simply a rationale it's
self-justification to legitimize their
choices after the fact
speaking of legitimizing choices after
the fact
nobody at fox has explained how this
toxic nonsense ended up on the airwaves
i know for a fact that many of the
people who work at fox do not agree with
this
do not want to be associated with it
but a decision was made by somebody
to do this report and air it
all the parties involved should explain
themselves and then they should be fired
also
oh are you promoting cancel culture you
want to cancel these people absolutely i
want to cancel them yes
they should be fired for sure named
shamed and fired
when you put dishonest
trans you know militant trans propaganda
on the airwaves
that's going to do and is doing
immeasurable harm to thousands of kids
then yeah you should be fired for that
fox speaks largely to a conservative
audience and nobody in the audience
wants any part of this
of all the people that were watching fox
on that friday when that than when that
report aired
how many of them wanted that
so this is propaganda made by and for an
audience that doesn't watch fox
and hates fox
and especially hates fox's actual
audience
but forget about conservative for a
moment okay put that aside
if fox news wants to call itself news
then it cannot put insane falsehoods and
radical far left lies and propaganda on
the air if you want to be a news
organization
especially this kind of propaganda worst
of all
propaganda which aims to exploit and
destroy children
so
fox's audience has to call the network
to account
i mean nothing less than a full
retraction an apology should be accepted
here
it's up to the audience to demand that
so the audience can decide whether they
just want to let this slide
as fox news celebrates pride month
putting up trans propaganda that again
would not be aired by any other major
network on tv right now
a lot of them would go close to what you
just saw from fox but they wouldn't even
go that far
suggesting that a toddler can choose her
own gender
when you hear that from the left but
even on cnn they would say it's a little
too far
maybe in a year or two we'll we'll be at
a point where we can put that out there
and not have any blow back
now fox's audience should have zero
tolerance policy
for propaganda of any kind especially
trans propaganda
[Music]
and you need to make sure that fox gets
that memo
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated